welcome to this video or ninja Sheba
okay it's a new opponent just a new
handle yep pretty new handle that's a
very high five minute rating okay um I
mean compared to the other ratings this
is what I was referring to okay let's go
with this Queens Indian opening that I'm
really don't play regularly but how
Queen a4 just interesting in this
particular position
can I go see five maybe kuna phone looks
a bit strange I mean not like terrible
or anything but just fields fields
uncommon let's say k checking
maybe I'm taking I don't know ok let's
take
no I shouldn't I shouldn't allow just
just Bishop g2 I have to do this I guess
and it's a tempo on the roof so I get
castles Bishop before it's not hitting
and yes to play a move that he probably
does not necessarily wants to play like
f3 for example group g1 okay he didn't
want any of that so he just retreated
okay how to play now knight c6 write a
six yes before maybe okay but before as
a temp or loss I mean not sure if it's a
loss of a temper but it's delazes
development even further I can try d phi
for example against that before is a
move i have to think about because it
just takes away the c5 square if we
cancel the half-light c5 and think I'm
okay would be a bit strange if not okay
Quincy two runs into the next tempo and
that means Queen d1 is the the almost
only move okay so be four and a five
things tanks yeah it should be okay at
least for a quality I think it's a bit
difficult to be ambitious in this
position it's very sound solid and okay
but since nothing exciting yeah I
thought rook a one-night be 34
simplifications
okay he can take with the bishop it's
not it's not a bad idea his structure is
this week the sea and a pond weaker than
mine but he has to bishop so you can
always some make this claim that the two
two bishops help to compensate for the
structure structural deficits okay so
let's straight then Jack came okay man
maybe I'm just running into night night
to be five now okay yeah well I don't
want to play something like d5 that
that's very very very boring
it's probably just equal but it's also
boring I to be 5 mm it's a bit difficult
too difficult to counter and some
interesting fashion and I can just go to
see 6am but not helping much with any
ambitions ok I expected that but I mean
the Queen trade is nothing that I
particularly dislike him Quincy sex even
bc successes coming into consideration
yes but where are you going where are
you going from here yeah i'm taking a
three at the end here it's not be
something that sets clear word i'm still
taking a 3k looked at you I guess if try
to be active with both rooks
it's not easy not not so easy if I am to
play e 2 a 3 they're both hanging it is
not even a pawn up yet okay someone
checking here now then look a 2 next I
guess King f1 is coming yeah probably I
can play look 12 c 2 as I rook a to c 21
min threatening rookie to he has 93
though an IT form
now you cannot see cannot play much
anyway so maybe maybe get the King
nearer okay 494 what exactly maybe try
to approach with the king check okay my
king is really quick I yeah I get the C
porn it should be quite good yeah he
wants to go if form maybe you have to
try to play this precaution can you save
this night f4 maybe for counter-attacks
check don't see it 95 I have g6 night h5
sorry not h5 I have she's like resign I
just resigned yeah okay when he has no
time that that's that's one additional
problem yeah there was pressing water
out of stone I mean I'm okay here it's
no no problem or anything but it's it's
very difficult to get anywhere
especially if it just plays normal move
this is giving black maybe a little
something okay
what is the computer suggestion down ah
k x and that's interesting once to just
see that's interesting wants to just
come compounds to just cover c5 and
combine or get this additional idea of a
night trap into this like rook a7 is
trapping the night loop cd1 the snare
sorry Luke CD 1 is the computer and then
look before checking this 0.8 for
whatever that that's worth okay so this
is probably ok but nothing special here
here ciao and this I don't know 0.3
according to the comp but this this
looks wrong yeah this looks wrong to me
maybe he can can save it still at night
23 and 93 ok yeah ok he's probably quick
enough there this is this is a funny
funny perpetual in a way what repetition
is wrong with the right word before and
after that is losing ok so he has to get
this end the quick attack on the porn if
I go here he's attacking that and I
cannot defend yeah ok king he takes now
I get the pawn and probably the game
yeah that wasn't wasn't very much but
you have to be persistent and then
continue to play sometimes um something
accurate movies helping you ok thanks
for watching